l'euro-2000 coup d'envoi demain soir sur
france 2 avec un match d'ouverture
belgique suède
tous les regards se tournent donc vers
les deux pays organisateurs la belgique
et les pays bas qui se disent prêts à
faire face à toute éventualité a
commencé par des débordements ou des
violences de la part des familles
polygames ce leur police est sur le pied
de guerre
comme ont pu le constater joël bruandet
et josé boulesteix à charleroi les
gendarmes disent avoir tout prévu
voici donc ce qu'on appelle ici le
centre d'accueil pour personnes arrêtées
vous voyez que les murs ont été
renforcés ce sont de plus en béton armé
pour éviter les mouvements de foule pour
éviter qu'ils puissent le faire tomber
la réputation certains fait qu' on ne
peut rien laisser dans la cellule qu'ils
pourraient être détruits ça pour ça que
les toilettes sont coulés dans du béton
et que les grilles en basset sont
particulièrement solides il a fallu un
mois et demi de travaux résultat 15
cellules qui pourront accueillir jusqu'à
1000 personnes
petite précision en belgique les
policiers peuvent procéder à des
arrestations dites administratives d'une
durée de 12 heures sur la base d'un
simple soupçon stade communal
on se prépare pour un match à hauts
risques angleterre allemagne ce sera le
17 juin prochain
pour autant les policiers refusent de
céder à la psychose
les supporters allemands les supporters
anglais qui vont me laisser ne sont pas
tous des hooligans
ils viennent aussi j'imagine pour faire
la fête je propose ici tous les matches
seront enregistrés au total 22 caméras
commandées depuis ce poste de contrôle
tant dans la partie dix d'entre elles
seront braqués en permanence sur les
tribunes à l'extérieur douze autres
filmeront les abords du stade pour
coordonner tout le dispositif de
sécurité
deux policiers un belge et un
néerlandais il dirige le très secret des
pays c'est ce bureau d'information et de
renseignement basé en hollande est
consacrée aux milliers de hooligans déjà
fiché c'est d'ici que l'on suivra le
déplacement et les agissements des
supporters les plus dangereuses
car le problème n'est plus dans les
stades
aujourd'hui suffisamment équipé pour
éviter les débordements
la violence du coup se développe à
l'extérieur eindhoven comme ailleurs ce
sont donc les habitations que l'on
protège
et c'est là que j'ai eu on a
l'impression d'être emprunt dont on
n'aime pas ça on peut même plus garer
notre voiture dans la rue mais
n'oublions pas qu'il ne s'agit que de
football
alors bienvenue à l'euro 2000